Karl Lagerfeld les
héritiers enfin dévoilées et peut-être
le montant était dévoilé quand il faut
déjà quatre ans ou 5 ans pour pour voilà
c'est que je peux vous promettre que
demain et je le souhaite pas mon ami de
tout cœur Jean-Mi meurt je pense qu'en
12 minutes le notaire a réglé le
problème il y a une boîte il y a une
voiture il y avait un scooter il y avait
une roue il y avait un pneus neige il y
avait un pneus neige
c'est bon on peut y aller
alors le 19 février donc euh le couture
qu'elle agafel meurt on le sait d'un
cancer quatre ans après donc cette
succession n'était pas réglées pourquoi
c'est compliqué on va le savoir avec
Roland Perez qui est spécialiste et
après il avait fait une liste également
des légataires de 1 à 10 à peu près ce
qu'ils vont toucher de 1 à 7 pardon
alors on dit qu'il a un appartement qui
est le terrain il y a un appartement il
est à Paris il y a un appartement rue de
Verneuil à côté de chez Gainsbourg un
appartement de 300 mètres carrés aussi
rue des Saints-Pères là où habitait
Bernard Tapie un pavillon à Louveciennes
un appartement à Monaco une librairie
des meubles de designers si à tout ça
et certains disent il avait tellement de
dettes fiscale qui reste plus rien il y
a toute du passif bref je n'en ai aucune
idée et donc le mieux pour tout ça c'est
d'accueillir un professionnel en
intéresse
[Applaudissements]
le mec avec un bouton
[Rires]
il y a deux trucs très importants il y a
l'héritage et bien sûr pourquoi vous
êtes toujours bronzé
non mais c'est le résultat du vélo que
je fais quotidiennement à Paris
d'un week-end de Pâques donc je suis pas
en vacances c'est vrai alors
effectivement on va se dire un petit peu
tout ce qui se passe donc une
voilà cet héritage aujourd'hui de la
liste des héritiers Bir il y avait une
grosse dette fiscale est-ce que plutôt
un actif qui va se partager ou un passif
qui vont refuser non ils ont été très
intelligents et lui d'ailleurs été très
intelligent avant de partir il a
absolument tout organisé et en fait il a
il a suggéré à ce que l'ensemble de ces
héritiers n'accepte le l'actif en vérité
qui a concurrence de cette actif c'est à
dire sans les dettes d'accord est-ce
qu'on appelle sous bénéfice d'inventaire
ou sous bénéfice d'accord et d'être payé
d'abord pour pouvoir récupérer que les
ex en gros siapti a des dettes c'était
pas pour eux s'il y a du positif et
visiblement c'est positif c'est positif
absolument tant à peu près alors le
montant total ce sera à peu près de 200
millions d'euros avec une dette fiscale
quand même d'un peu plus de 20 millions
d'euros et en fait ce qu'il a demandé
également à la fois que c'est héritiers
ne touchent que les actifs donc il ne
supporte absolument pas les dettes mais
il a demandé également à ce que ce ne
soit pas des biens qui soient partagés à
part quelques meubles des choses comme
ça il a demandé à ce que tout soit
d'abord inventorier vendu une partie
pour les dettes et vendu ensuite en
répartition donc tout va être vendu
c'est que de l'argent voilà exactement
parce qu'il n'a pas voulu c'est très
difficile il y a les valeurs qui sont
fluctuantes entre les collections qu'il
a entre les livres entre les billes là
où il a raison c'est que quand vous avez
pas beaucoup d'argent si vous
hérité d'un appartement de 300 mètres
carrés vous pouvez pas l'entretenir non
et puis et puis il y a quand même
quelque chose dont personne ne parle
c'est qui a une incidence fiscale
c'est-à-dire que tous ces héritiers ne
sont pas les enfants
qui vont se retrouver avec 60 %
60% à payer alors on prend un exemple
par exemple sur 200 millions on a 20
millions qu'on va enlever pour payer ses
dettes
alors on va il va rester à peu près 180
millions on va enlever 30 %
effectivement qui vont être donnés mais
par exemple sur ces 30 % ça fait trois
fois 18 millions ça fait à peu près 54
millions sur ces 54 millions il va lui
rester en réalité une fois qu'il aura
payé tous les droits 20 millions c'est
une blague c'est terminé par 7 non non
qui est le plus gros celui qui avait été
le plus sur les 30% des 180 millions
c'est-à-dire que normalement il aurait
dû avoir pardon 180 x 0,3 et lui aurait
dû avoir 54 millions il va en avoir 20
dans la poche tout le reste va à l'État
et les autres vont toucher en moyenne à
part le chat de bien mon petit 1 million
5 pour le chat et la minou ils vont
toucher à peu près 10 millions sur les
20 millions qui vont percevoir alors
parce que les autres on va quand même en
parler effectivement donc cette non ont
été
révélées donc 30 % le plus un truc qui
évitera le plus c'est Baptiste Giabiconi
en seconde position c'est Sébastien
jandot moi j'avais reçu on ne connait
moi mais c'était vraiment son son nom à
tout faire son chauffeur sur 20 ans
quand même pendant 20 ans il lui avait
dit d'ailleurs je ne veux plus que tu
travailles après mon départ et on va
dire la vérité il s'aimait pas du tout
avec diabiconi il avait vu arriver un
peu comme une petite chose qu'elle est
mauvais piqué le pognon et lui dit c'est
moi qui est tenu la main de Karl
Lagerfel lorsqu'il est mort et pas du
tout Baptiste et les deux ne s'aiment
pas et même Sébastien a sorti un bouquin
dans lequel il dit pas du bien de battre
tout le monde sait que c'était l'un de
ces petits défauts il adorait monter
tous ces garçons là les uns contre les
autres étaient un peu des rapports qu'on
a un peu moins Virginie Viard sur le DA
channel Caroline le bar qui vient sur
son image Amanda Arlette bon après
pardon il ne connaît pas tellement et
pardon sa chatte alors là je m'adresse à
l'avocat
est-ce qu'on a le droit en France
légalement je connais pas les règles
américaines est-ce qu'on a le droit de
faire hériter un animal d'un million et
demi d'euros non en fait on vous dit et
la loi évolué pour les animaux vous dit
que c'est bien un être doué de
sensibilité doué d'intelligence doué
tout ce qu'on veut mais il reste dans la
catégorie des personnes il reste un bien
en réalité c'est à dire que le le chat
est un meuble le chat l'animal est un
meuble à partir de là il ne peut pas
irriter mais c'est pas lui diriger de
passer soit par une fondation une
association ou une personne
mais du coup si c'est un meuble
est-ce que moi du coup si c'est ça j'ai
le droit de vendre le chat un million et
demi d'euros à quelqu'un s'il en veut
le chat
charge de s'occuper donc c'est à l'aigle
avec chargeur
la semaine mais droit par contre
d'acheter des petites sceller un peu
Malines d'acheter deux trois pâtés
premiers prix et puis de garder tout
merci
la question que j'aimerais poser et qui
moi me choque quand même beaucoup
je veux pas du tout parler des morts
mais je vais en parler j'aimerais qu'on
m'explique quand même pourquoi des gens
comme moi par exemple des gens lambda on
a des contre-fiscaux tous les trois
quatre ans où on nous fait chier pour un
plein d'essence et j'aimerais savoir
pourquoi Karl Lagerfeld avait une dette
de 20 millions d'euros à fiscal tout le
monde s'en fout Johnny Hallyday 30
millions tout le monde s'en fout ça
passe des coups de téléphone à Sarkozy
mystère de l'Intérieur pourquoi les gens
qui ont beaucoup d'argent la fiscalité
c'est quand ça les arrange non ça s'en
fout on s'en fout pas puisque par
définition il va les payer cette somme
là aujourd'hui le fait avec son prix
c'était des dettes oui c'était des
dettes mais si il va les payer sur ses
biens enfin aujourd'hui non j'entends
mais nous on laisse pas nous nous on
nous laisse pas nous pas ça nous nous
cotons les impôts qui arrivent on a 10 %
de machin on a vous avez d'abord il y a
toutes les procédures de contestation
qui dure un certain temps il y a des
procédures de vérification ensuite il y
a des procédures de conciliation de
transactions donc tout ça prend un
certain temps je pense qu'il était
extrêmement bien entouré anti enfin en
homme de loi en fiscaliste et autres et
donc il a dû accuser tous les recours
pour arriver avec ce redressement parce
que cette date-là l'issue de la
redressement elle date de 2013 10 ans
de racines
il dit je dois tout à 4 voilà donc c'est
pas hasard arrêtez de penser que les
succès c'est des hasards
vous vous permettez de juger
quelqu'un de son argent voilà qu'il est
mort
mais vous dites ouais il a rien fait
dans sa vie il arrive
comme ça
il y a rien fait de sa vie maintenant il
est riche j'ai dit il est arrivé une
main devant une main derrière donc il
avait rien au départ il est il hérite de
20 millions c'est tant mieux c'est super
alors pour finir
juste pour finir par rapport à la
procédure de dette concernant Lagerfel
elle est pas du tout terminée donc
excusez-moi un autre
ça vous arrive souvent un plateau chez
nous vous avez remarqué
elle n'est pas du tout terminé et il est
pas encore acté que la dette sera en
dessous de ce qu'ils vont toucher la
première chose et ils ont accepté
l'héritage mais ils attendent encore que
ce soit validé pour pouvoir l'accepter
et la deuxième chose aussi c'est que
Carl Lagerfeld il a fait son testament à
Monaco il a même fait d'une façon
manuscrite un peu à l'ancienne etc et à
Monaco moi sur ce que je me suis laissé
dire c'est que c'est 16% et non 60%
quand on l'aide à un tiers donc il s'est
arrangé aussi pour que les héritiers
puissent toucher le paquet oui mais lui
il l'est il est résident monégasque
vivent en France et c'est le droit
français et ils ont accepté la
succession depuis le départ encore une
fois sous bénéfice d'inventaire
c'est-à-dire
bien sûr de toutes les dettes donc ils
ont été relanque je vais vous offrir à
Daloz parce que ça fait deux fois que
vous rendez compte qu'en face on a des
avocats bien plus brillants que vous
prenez s'il vous plaît à bosser non non
c'est extrêmement précis un dernier mot
à propos de Monaco Caroline de Monaco
donc c'est elle elle meubles ouais juste
des bêtes
à des personnes déterminées c'était
hyper clair merci d'avoir regardé votre
weekend pour ça parce que c'était très
clair merci beaucoup